this is a classic example of where you
need to solemnize this data because it's
just too much like I don't know anything
really just by looking at this set of
done okay
one of the first ways that we can sort
of prepare the data before we interpret
it is to say well I suppose we could
work out the mean suppose we can do that
we cook a median or range we know how to
do all of those things but if you found
out the mean you could strip out a lot
of valuable information there for
example remember I said before he's a
set of four scores and they have the
mean that we were interested in from 12
he's another service for it has the same
meaning but I argue it's a very
different set of data it's got
characteristics that completely separate
it from the other one does that make
sense so even though I could find out
the mean and it will probably give me
something useful I'm probably going to
miss out a lot too so before I get to
this sort of an intermediate step to be
able to understand know the difference
in meaning between this and this the
first thing the first school in account
is grouping now if we've looked at
grouping before so I'm trying to
actually jog your memory a little bit so
you can see now the bottom here what
they're asking us to do first is take
these 48 scores I'm not gonna ask you to
write them up I'm going to leave it up
there but can we organize them into
groups such that we have groups of 10
like a 0 to 10 11 to 20 21 to 30 and so
on and we would use like a tally for
that right that might be useful or we
might decide actually that's too fine
detail still there's still too much
information there maybe you only want to
go and zoom out even further okay we
group Donna because that way we can see
everything better you do those
information though every time you sort
of go down this way like if you're
looking at a graph you clearly don't
have all of the fine individual
just getting it overall okay but there's
a little more useful to be able to
interpret and get something together so
I'm gonna start us just to get you my
going by leaving this town up here
I suggest you draw up for yourself at
the table on the left hand side you want
these groups of ten okay
we call these classes so there's the 0
to 10 plus the 11 to 20 Clause the 21 to
3 in some bells
yes yeah okay so we'll label those
monsters and then we'll keep it tally as
we go from left to right on the data
we've got here I will see if we can get
some meaning out of this so you might
notice this I'm very glad to hear can
you see if you set up your table like
mine that will look ever so slightly
different to this what's the difference
it's the stun endpoint okay now I'll
just point out think about this because
I need you I need you to get away from
what's the what's the right answer to
what's the point of doing this right ds1
you get done dares to you have a look at
what it might be represented like
visually ds3 you summarized it
the decibel what's the point what are we
getting at what are we searching for
we're looking for patterns trend yeah
yeah
that's exactly the point that I'm
talking about right now
so the fader it's different
doesn't disguise the fact that do you
have a shape that looks like this
do you have it and the reason why is
because if you move all these brackets
up or down one it's still the same data
and the shape is still there so it
doesn't matter what the class is not
really about this
the class matters oh why hey George are
you guys ready yeah okay
so I'll come back to this and I will
show you what page it's on but I just
want to point out okay well what is
useful about this right and what's
useful is I can see meaning here in here
this shape by the way it's really really
important I've mentioned it before it's
called the normal distribution the ds5
is called the normal distribution so
we're gonna be studying that a lot it's
really great it's actually something I
think on between an extension once a you
guys okay after you draw this thing the
follow-up question is just like the esta
- said what does it look like how can I
draw it so I'm gonna save you a bit of
time I don't need you to draw it right
now these are what the graphs would look
like if you drew these now can either
tell me what are these called
so we call this that proper name is a
frequency histogram now this is really
important we distinguish between a
histogram
versus a bar chart now this is a bit
weird
I wonder if you are thinking back to ds2
right I one of the key differences is do
you see all of these columns they're all
just shoved right up against each other
there's no gaps between them okay now
that's not just arbitrary what have you
got okay so number one I think it does
look a little easy you can see the shape
of it there's another reason though
actually more than one space is a thing
I suppose what are you comparing to yeah
yeah okay so let's just imagine can you
speak to for a second if these bars here
what orgeous vertical lines instead of
bars okay ba-ba-ba-ba-ba I feel like I
could still can Hannah what other reason
is there yeah what do you mean by old
one thing
yeah yeah alright so let me give you a
perfect example of where you would do a
bar chart with separation as opposed to
a histogram I had something like this
maybe I could say sales and I could say
something like this so if this is what
the canteen sold over the course of a
normal thing sushi
drinks sausage rolls I'm hungry can you
tell okay
do you see that even though all these
things are sales so I guess they'd
represent money wasn't like that there
really are quite separate to one another
does that make sense it's not like oh
yeah there's the sushi grease category
right this is not they're not common
things I'm try to compare them but as I
was trying to get at right they're not
the same kinds of things like these are
all scores in a class does that make
sense
there's one more thing I want to add
which is this arm they're not individual
scores their classes remember that so
there's actually a whole range within
each of these bars so having a sort of
width to that and having no gaps sort of
helps us here